I flew jet Suite you ever flown that is
that the one where it's like a shared PJ
yeah they put a bunch of like normal
airplane seats on a private jet so it's
like 30 people or 40 people or something
like that
um it feels like a normal flight were
you scared getting in this thing I mean
it is a smaller plane so you do feel the
bumps and [__] a lot more yeah I think
I'd have more confidence hopping in a
plane like a jumper plane with Luke than
I would one of these and Luke has flown
once wait what he flew a plane in high
school you told me yeah I was in Middle
School but yeah in middle school yeah I
was a co-pilot with my uncle but yes
how'd it feel
like flying a plane
yeah but
was it scary
what was that like like flying an
airplane [__] [__] dumbass
foreign